don't worry fellas i got something for
you
it's the christmas season and uh leticia
saboteur saboter has a christmas song
for you
don't worry folks we're fair here
christmas merry merry christmas merry
merry christmas
merry merry christmas
merry christmas
[Music]
someone to depend
[Music]
all i know is the way you feel
whenever you're around
[Music]
you think she's had surgery
[Music]
santa claus
[Music]
she kind of ripped me for her age good
for her
[Music]
to another place
is this i'm sorry they say there's no
good nuke there's no
there's no new good christmas music
well guess what there is move out of the
way mariah carey we have a new christmas
song
he's remembering having sex with her
i can't put the blame on frozen asian on
this one hey frozen
why don't you tell them who sent me this
[Music]
a feeling i can't hide from you
[Music]
okay the back's not that great that's
that's where you could really see the
[Music]
age
[Music]
i have sex with santa
turnouts he has hiv
[Music]
so she had sex with the three wise men
this is the music jesus would listen to
if he was alive today
i think is the point of well this
i think is the point of all this okay if
jesus
were on this planet today he would be
listening to this
brian knight 20 thank you mr knight hey
you know what mr night your dad i'll
call you brian
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus who is this is her without makeup
[Music]
on
so i mean obviously she's in shape i
mean we would could see that with her
abs and stuff
but what's up with her face is it too
much surgery
[Music]
oh what was that
why they cut it off before before they
finish kissing man
what [ __ ] teases
is it a tree i'm it might be a train
it might be a tr is it a train let's
figure this out
i mean no i i'm i'm serious now is it a
train
i don't think so i think it's a woman
i'm pretty sure it's a woman if i had to
guess it's a woman that's had too much
surgery but it's a woman the legs it's
a woman i think it's a woman
pretty sure it's a woman if i had to
guess
oh my god what bucket santa has a boner
what's going on with this video
back up a little bit this is the kai
kissing thing okay one more time there
we go
[Music]
why why does santa have a boner
is he looking at the same person
holy [ __ ] this is awesome
i'm i found my new favorite christmas
video and song and everything
this is my new favorite thing of the
world
santa has a boner
oh [ __ ]
that's exactly what i'm saying should in
such good shape with her abs but her ass
looks like 90 years old i'm trying to
figure that out too
oh it wasn't a phoner it was the remote
hey guys it wasn't a boner
it was a remo you [ __ ] sick freaks
thought it was a boner
weirdo you [ __ ] weirdo you you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] weird people
thought it was a boner it was a remote
control the whole time
[Music]
[Applause]
see she was born a woman see 1966 in
spain looks
born a girl it's a woman i told he was a
[Music]
woman
my son
[Music]
merry christmas i guess merry merry
christmas
merry merry christmas
um merry merry christmas
i am
i wonder what other videos she has
wouldn't hurt to check it out right
let's see
the same channel i mean i'm just trying
to say that
of course i mean that would make sense i
i could i would 100 see that
i can see how she wouldn't be from i'd
be surprised if she i would be surprised
if she
wasn't from miami
[Music]
all right no i mean this seriously look
again
good for her she's the age that she is
and that's the shape she's in
but is is
is is some is something off with the abs
i'm just trying to figure it out
i i mean maybe she really isn't that
[ __ ]
but again impressive shape that she's in
but like her midsection doesn't match
her like her legs aren't in the same
shape as her midsection or
arms like it's i'm really trying to
figure this out
what is fat sculpting i don't know what
that is
it's not a dude it's a woman mommy milf
mommy was just jealous because she's not
at the
cgi beach right now
[Music]
oh
she said go to hell
beautiful beautiful look at that
she's beautiful wow
she is just she's
lovely
[Music]
i'm sorry we could stop i i just was
did you get curious right you get
curious what other songs
that they did did you know she had a
christmas song last year
she did we're gonna play it i know you
guys are gonna be mad at me but i have
to see last year's christmas song let's
see if it's an improvement
there's no music
did our song get muted
this is weird look look there's no
there's no audio
huh you guys got [ __ ] lucky
you guys got really really lucky that i
also found this
really lucky because you almost missed
out on a great song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm at cfrotc bye bye
[Music]
is she popular i don't think she's
popular anywhere to be honest with you
her name is leticia sabadel
s-a-b-a-t-e-r
a big large man voice my morning firm
please stop pushing us
we all have suffered enough please stop
this madness okay you know what you're
right you have suffered enough
i'm sorry